MIKE: If you want
to find old stuff,
you have to go back
to where it all began.
The East Coast.
MIKE: Alright,
we're getting close, dude.
This is it.
[knock on door]
MIKE: Hey, you Denise?
DENISE: Yeah, hi!
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet you.
This is Frank.
DENISE: Nice to meet you.
FRANK: How are you doing?
Nice to meet you.
DENISE: Hi, Frank.
MIKE: Talked to Dani
on the phone?
DENISE: Yes, I did.
MIKE: Okay, she said Brad's got
...some stuff?
DENISE: He's got stuff.
Do you want to come in?
MIKE and FRANK: Yeah, of course.
DENISE: Alright.
MIKE: Of course, thank you.
DENISE: Brad!
We got some visitors.
MIKE: Hey!
You Brad?
I'm Mike, nice to meet you.
This is Frank.
FRANK: Brad, how you doing?
Frank.
BRAD: Nice to meet you.
FRANK: Pleasure.
So Danielle says
your dad used to
work with Marilyn Monroe.
BRAD: That's true.
He worked with her
on a very early movie that
she didn't even get credit for.
FRANK: Was she Norma Jeane
or was she Marilyn Monroe?
BRAD: She was Marilyn Monroe.
FRANK: Okay.
BRAD: My dad was a very
interesting person.
He was interested
in photography all of his life.
BRAD: So I gathered together
a couple of
pictures of my father
with Marilyn Monroe
in some of the early days.
MIKE: Oh, Frank,
I'm standing right next to it.
FRANK: Let me see.
MIKE: These are original photos?
BRAD: These are the originals.
BRAD: My father
started out on set
taking still pictures,
and worked his way up
to being a motion picture
camera operator.
BRAD: Here's a picture
of my father
dancing with Marilyn Monroe.
MIKE: Oh, get outta here!
Look at that!
FRANK: Wow, look at that.
MIKE: Frank, who?
That's so awesome!
FRANK: That is... wow.
MIKE: [laughs]
FRANK: She's beautiful.
MIKE: Can you imagine?
FRANK: Can you imagine
how big a blow-up
I would have of that
if that was me?
MIKE: [laughs]
FRANK: That would be like
poster-size, life-size.
MIKE: Easy.
FRANK: Come on.
MIKE: Brad's dad
was making big moves.
Marilyn handed him the ball,
and he ran with it.
God bless him.
MIKE: Where else can
we look around at?
BRAD: Ah,
right up here to the left.
Have multiple generations
of accumulated things.
FRANK: Whoa!
BRAD: I have so many
items in this house
belonging to the family.
At least five generations from
my great-great-grandparents,
great-grandparents,
grandparents,
parents, and myself.
BRAD: In a way it's like
living in a historical society.
In fact, all the time, I go
to visit historical societies
and you'll see things
in the house and I'll say,
"Oh, yeah,
I've got one of those.
I've got that over there."
MIKE: Yeah, and they're like,
"What?"
BRAD: Yeah.
MIKE: [laughs]
BRAD: What my goals are,
I'm working on
restoring a lot of the house,
making it more functional
and you know,
I have too much to hang onto,
so I'm trying to pare down,
and there's items
that I want to find
another home for,
because I just
have too many.
FRANK: Hey, Brad!
BRAD: Yeah.
FRANK: What's the story
on this bear?
BRAD: That's an original
teddy bear that I believe
was my father's toy when he
was a, you know, a little kid.
It's got to be going back
to the, you know, 1920s.
FRANK: I can see it's a Steiff.
FRANK: You know, it's got
a little damage on here,
you can tell the age of it,
it's made of straw.
It would have had like
a little button here,
would have said "Steiff."
That's missing.
FRANK: It's got some
damage on it, you know?
It's been well played with.
One eye's missing,
a lot of the fur's missing.
But this still
is a collectible piece.
FRANK: Now if this was in mint,
mint condition, I mean,
like never played with,
it could realize up to $1,000.
BRAD: Wow.
FRANK: Yeah.
This, in this condition,
anywhere from
300 to 425.
And there's enough of it here
that it's collectible.
I would feel comfortable...
$200.
BRAD: Alright, sure thing.
$200, it's yours.
FRANK: You got a deal.
Alrighty, I like it.
FRANK: For an entry-level
collector,
or somebody that just
wants a Steiff bear,
this is a cool piece.
MIKE: A lot of people have
passed in and out of this home,
but their stuff is still here.
MIKE: Brad understands
the importance of that.
But he's still trying
to navigate
what he wants to keep,
and what he wants to sell.
Today wasn't a huge pick,
but we had moments...
and those moments were enough.
MIKE: I tell you what.
I saw a lot of stuff today
I've never seen before.
And that's half of it
right there.
Thank you very much.
God bless you.
FRANK: Thanks, Brad.
BRAD: Great seeing you guys.
MIKE: We'll see you
down the road.
BRAD: It's hard to let
some of these things go,
but I'm happy that
they'll go to homes where...
than just sitting
tucked away in a closet.
[honks horn]
MIKE: See you, buddy!
BRAD: Have a good trip!